now from inflation to the border to the
staggering rise in violent crime
the biden administration is an utter
train wreck it's so bad that some in the
democratic party are wondering
if joe will even run for a second term
these same democrats are also worried
that kamala harris is
not capable of beating any gop let alone
you know who joining us now with
reaction is former hud secretary
ben carson secretary carson thank you
sir
and of course when we think about you
know who ever
the man who's always present donald
trump uh
a man who uh understood your value and
uh relied on you such a great deal uh we
think of him
as we watch this madness unfold with
what he
and you and so many others in his
administration accomplished
what are your thoughts on this fourth of
july weekend with what's happening in
the country
well the people we really need to think
about are those
who are in grave danger of
death and harm because we
have relinquished our respect for law
and order
you know when i was a kid growing up
spent a lot of time in the projects and
in places where there was a lot of
violence
and people relied heavily on the police
to stop some of that
so when we talk about defunding the
police
and you know taking away their
immunity of some type and they lay back
because they're afraid to risk their
careers and
risk their livelihood for their family
the people that we are really
hurting are those that they are
protecting
and i think we really need to begin to
emphasize that
because you know the the left frequently
talks about racism
the people who are being hurt are the
very ones that they claim
are being hurt by racism and they're the
ones who are responsible for it
so you know we need to just sort of drop
the pretenses
and say who is being hurt and how can we
stop that from happening
and you know sir that is a a perfect
point
and a very wise point because they the
left claims the democrats claim to
represent people of color
women gays all people who live on the
fringe minorities of all sorts
and yet all of their policies sir
destroy
those actual lives over and over again
the urban areas of this country
incredibly important to american cities
being burnt down businesses destroyed
and those businesses owned by people of
color
this seems to be it can't i mean even a
broken clock
is right twice a day it seems like
you've got to really have an agenda to
accomplish this
for for this kind of destruction to
continue sure
and logic and common sense needs to come
back
you know if in a place like san
francisco you don't prosecute people who
go in and shoplift
what are you going to do you're going to
increase the amount of shoplifting
and other types of crimes that are going
on if you're
having cashless bill you're releasing
criminals
you're not doing anything to deter those
actions
what needs to be done is some of the
things that were done in the previous
administration
where you encourage people employers to
go into the jails
and to begin working with some of those
inmates
and in many cases actually giving them
jobs so that when they come out
they have an alternative they don't go
back to the same situation
that's why the recidivism rates are so
high if we take the politics out of it
and start thinking about the people
and what can we do for the people you
know this is not a republican or a
democrat thing this is a people thing
do we want to govern for the people or
do we want to govern
for political power and we've seen i
think it's fair to say the democrats
clearly don't have people in mind they
what they have in mind
is gaining more power more money
more influence and we seem to be cannon
fodder at this point sir
and what of course we know with as over
this weekend
americans have got to realize and i
think we can reinforce here
that they're not alone that what they
see is not what anyone wants
regular democrats don't want it they are
the ones being destroyed and hurt
in these blue cities and states all of
this is a shock to so many
uh what would you say for uh republicans
this weekend
when it comes to their democrat family
members
how can they come together on this
because this unites us all
well i would say first of all what's
going to happen in chicago
this weekend yeah how many people are
going to be shot how many people are
going to be murdered
why does no one care about that why
are why are they trying to blame someone
else for that
why are they trying to say it's guns
when they have the strictest gun laws of
any place
obviously it's the heart of people
we need to start re-imagining
what life can be like for people who are
disadvantaged it can actually be very
good
growing up in a disadvantaged situation
myself it was
people were always saying you can't make
it until i started reading
about scientists and surgeons and
explorers and entrepreneurs and i
realized that
the person who has the most to do it
happens to you is you
but there are others of us who can help
those people
and that's what we really need to be
thinking about and if we really cared we
would be thinking about that
yes sir i you know i'm sorry we're we're
at it at the end here but this really is
about realizing that
none of this is normal that we can make
a difference and of course
you're a great inspiration to so many
thank you for joining me tonight hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else